[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم مشاهدينا هذه
الخامسه ونبدا بالعناوين
[تصفيق]
بعد الدبابات محادثات لامداد كليب بطائرات
اف 16 وروسيا رود اجواء اوكرانيا مغلقه
قائد قوات قصد يؤكد للعربيه نيه تركيا
شانه هجوم على عين العرب وين في اي علاقه
مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
الازمه القضائيه
تتصاعد احتجاج واشتباقا امام قصر العدل
على عرقله التحقيق
[موسيقى]
المعارضه التركيه تجتمع الى الاتفاق على
منافس اردوغان في الانتخابات المقبله
اذا المشاهدين البدايه من تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا وصف رئيس الوفد الروسي في
محادثات فيينا حول الامن العسكريه
والسيطره على التسلح قسطنطين
وصف طائره اف 16 و طائرات 29 باسلحه القرن
الماضي قال انه لا يستبعد ان يزود الغرب
اوكرانيا بهذه الاسلحه اضاف ان الاسلحه
الروسيه اكثر تطورا كما تحدث رئيس الوفد
الروسي فيينا حول الامن العسكري والسيط
على التسلح عن ان الاجواء الاوكرانيه تحت
سيطره موسكو وقال جبريلوف كما تعاملت
روسيا مع هذه التهديدات في وقت سابق
ستتعامل معها مستقبلا
وتصريحات المسؤول العسكري الروسي طبعا
جاءت ردا على تقرير نشرته صحيفه الفينانشل
تايمز والذي اشار فيه الى محادثات حول
ارسال طائره اف 16 الى اوكرانيا مسؤول في
شركه لوكد مارتن صرح انه في ظل توجه الغرب
لتقديم المزيد من الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
فانها ستزيد انتاجها من الطائرات طائرات
اف 16 حيث ان بعض الدول ستعيد تصدير
طائراتها الامريكيه لكيف طبعا لحمايه
مجالها الجوي في ماء شددت الشركه انها لن
تنخرط في المحادثات مباشره البيت الابيض
ما زال على الموقف حتى الان الموقف
الرافضي لتزويد اوكرانيا بالمقاتله مشدده
على انه يجب الحصول على موافقه الحكومه
الامريكيه في حال بيع او حتى نقل مقاتلات
امريكيه الى دوله ثالثه اما بالنسبه لكيف
قالت المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان قوات بلادها
تحتاج الى مدفعيه بعيده المدى لشن هجوم
مضاد قبل تجميع الصفوف الروسيه المخابرات
الاوكرانيه كشفت قيام روسيا بانشائي
مستودعات عسكريه على بعد 80 كم من خطوط
المواجهه ولهذا تحتاج اوكرانيا بحسب
التصريحات الى صواريخ بعيده المدى
لاستهداف المستودعات العسكريه الروسيه
هديه الدبابات الثمينه من المانيا وامريكا
وغيرهما لم تكفي كيف الرئيس الاوكرانيز
الانسكي يطمع الان بصواريخ بعيده المدى
ومقاتلات الجويه بهدف التصدي للقوات
الروسيه التي تقاتل على اراضيها
باحدى اكبر شركات تصنيع السياحي في العالم
للدخول على خط الازمه لكن مارتن الامريكيه
المصنعه لمقاتلات اف 16 اعلنت عن
استعدادها لزياده انتاج تلك المقاتلات دون
التدخل في اي محادثات لتزويد اوكرانيا بها
وانما ستعوض البلدان التي ستدعم اوكرانيا
عبر ارسال واحده من اشرس المقاتلات وافقا
ما كتبته صحيفه
سنزيد من انتاج طائره اف 16 لمساعدتي اي
دوله تختار القيام بعمليات لتلك الطائرات
للمساعده في الصراع القائم في اوكرانيا
لن تنفذ من دون مباركه البيت الابيض فلا
يحق لاي دوله تمتلك المقاتلات الامريكيه
ان ترسلها لدوله الثالثه دون موافقه
واشنطن والتي ما زالت ثابته على موقفها
رافضه لارسال اف 16 اوكرانيا خوفا من ان
تتحول لاداه انتقام تهاجم بها كيف اراضي
روسيا لكن لا ننسى انه واشنطن كانت ترفض
سابقا ارسل الدبابات قبل ان يتغير موقفها
نحن على اتصال المتضمن مع الاوكرانيين
بشان احتياجاتهم وطلباتهم وفي هذا الوقت
ليس لدينا ما نعلن عنه بخصوص طائرات اف 16
تعادات عسكريه مستمره يقدمها الغرب
لاوكرانيا منذ بدايه زحف الروسي لم تصبح
محل جدلا كما الان كونها كانت في الغالب
اسلحه للدفاع عن النفس الا ان تغير منح
المساعدات باتجاه الاسلحه الهجوميه ابتداء
بدبابات ابرامز فتح الحديث حول خطوه اكبر
واخطر في الحرب طالت لنحو عاما من دون
دبابات او مقاتلات فكيف ان وصلت
الى عمر العربيه
المزيد معنا مناكير مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه بدايه نبدا بالتطورات
الميدانيه خبرنا عن اخر التطورات روسي
لديها تصريحات بالفعل وتهديدات ولكنها
تنفذ ايضا على الارض وصلت لكيف كيف هو
الوضع
مساء الخير في الحقيقه كما توقع الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني في بدايه الهجمه الصباحيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ الروسيه
توقعت ان يكون هناك اطلاق لحوالي 30
صاروخا قبل اطلاق الصواريخ طبعا كان هنالك
اطلاق لطائرات شاهد كما افادتنا نتالي
المتحدث باسم القوات المشتركه الجنوبيه
وقالت ان هذه الطائرات شاهد من طراد شاهد
هي لارباك والاستنبات الدفاع الجوي على
الاوكراني بعد ذلك كانت الهجمه بالضربات
الصاروخيه التي بلغت 30 صاروخا اطلقت من
بحر قزوين ومن البحر الاسود وايضا واطلقت
عن طريق طائرات همم
طائرات تو 95 الاستراتيجيه من اراضي
الاتحاد الروسي طبعا الطائرات اطلقت يعني
سته طائرات اطلقت هذه الصواريخ الاستهداف
كان لعدد كبير من الولايات بل يعني وصل
الى اقصى الغرب الاوكراني في مدينه الفيف
وكذلك طبعا التركيز كان على الولايات في
وسط الدوله الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن كيف وعن
الولايات في الوسط وكذلك طبعا الولايات في
الشرق وفي الجنوب القصف ولكن استطاع
الدفاع الجوي ان يسقط معظم هذه الصواريخ
خاصه تلك التي ارسلت نحو العاصمه التي
بلغت 15 مره صاروخ سجل سجلت عمليه وصول في
العاصمه كيف في احد همم المنشات في احد
المنشات الحيويه للطاقه كذلك في مدينه
اديسا تم استهداف منشئتين هانتين للطاقه
الامر الذي يجب عنه طبعا همم عطل كبير جدا
الان قد تكون قدسه دون كهرباء لعده ايام
كذلك اثر الضربه في كيف اثرت على وضع
الكهرباء في وكذلك ستؤثر لايام
في منطقه عن انها للمواطنين يختبئون
بالملاجئ خلال هذا القصف على كل اسمح لي
ان انتقل الى كاتيا لانه التطورات ليست
فقط ميدانيه مرتبطه طبعا بالميدان ولكنها
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه التي يمكن ان
تستلمها اكيف من الغرب الان نتحدث عن
طائرات مختلفه همم من موسكو معنى مراسله
العربيه كاتيا تعمي اهلا بك كاتيا الى اي
حد تاخذ موسكو هذه التصريحات الصحفيه
والتسريبات كما يقال على محمل الجلد
مرحبا ميسون حقيقه كل ما يرد الان من
تصريحات حول تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه جديده
يتم الرد عليه مباشره من قبل الكريم اليوم
اتحدث المتحدث الرسمي باسم الكرملينز
مترفسك قال ان الغرب يزيد من تزويد
لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه وهذا يجعله طرفا في
النزاع طرف مباشر وليس غير مباشر كما
يعتبر الاوروبيون من جانب اخر كان هناك
مسؤول روسي تحدث عن زياده الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه هو سيزيد فقط من رقعه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
طبعا هو لم يستبعد ان يتم تزويد اوكراني
ايضا بطائرات او بمقاتلات وهذا طبعا
معتبره بان روسيا تسيطر على الاجواء في
اوكرانيا لذلك لا لن يكون هناك ابدا تاثير
على العمليه العسكريه وحتى ان الدبابات
ستصل الى همم اوكرانيا هي لن تغير ابدا من
ميزان القوه على الارض خليني اسال الاطار
حذيفه حول قضيه همم السيطره على الاجواء
الى اي حد هي دقيقه حذيفه هل من معلومات
من الجانب الاوكراني حول ذلك او تحركات
على الارض على الاقل فيما يتعلق بالاجواء
وخاصه انه شفنا كثير من المسؤولين
الغربيين ياتون ويذهبون منكياف
في الحقيقه يعني السيطر
القائد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه قال انه
الان اصبح الدفاع الجوي قادر على العمل
بالنسبه بللغه سبعه و76
همم يعني عندما وهذا واضح طبعا عند في
الضربات الصاروخيه التي ينفذها الاتحاد
الروسي اليوم اطلق ثلاثين صاروخا سجل طبعا
سقوط صاروخ او صاروخين والبقيه بقيه
الاصابات هي كانت نتيجه شضايا في بعض
المناطق لذلك نسبه همم نسبه قدره الدفاع
الجوي ااه يعني اصبحت عاليه جدا وهذا طبعا
المساعدات الغربيه ونحن مازلنا همم طبعا
تعلمين ان همم اوكرانيا ما زالت تنتظر
مزيد من اسلحه الدفاع الجوي خاصه بطاريات
باتريوت التي سوف تصل الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه قريبا والتي بالفعل بدات
القوات الاوكرانيه التدريب على استخدامها
في الاراضي الالمانيه وكذلك في الولايات
المتحده
هو قريبا سوف تكون البطاريات تعمل في
اوكرانيا والجلوس سوف يعودون للعمل
نعم حذيفه عندما نتحدث عنها روسيا تنظر
اليها على انها مباشره او تدخل مباشر من
قبل الغرب كاتيا روسيا تقول هذا الكلام
طبعا الغرب يقول انه لن يتدخل مباشره كيف
لها ان تتعاطى مع ما تراه موسكو من انه
تدخل مباشر غربي الان من خلال دعم موسكو
بمثل هذه الاسلحه وهنا لا اتحدث فقط عن
الطائره ولكن ايضا عن الدبابات وهو ما
اصبح مؤكدا الان
ميسون كم ذكرت ان روسيا تعتبر ااا وكما
كان هناك تصريحات سابقه للكريم لان هذا
ينقل الصراع الى مستوى جديد ومسك تعتبر ان
تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الاسلحه هو المستوى
يعني
مره تحدث عن هذه النقطه تحديدا
في خطه واضحه او او رد واضح كيف ستتعامل
موسكو مع هذا المستوى الجديد من التعاطي
مع الازمه توسيع الرقيه الميدانيه فيما
يتعلق للمواجه ام ماذا
هو حقيقه كما يقول الكريم هو سيؤثر هذا
تزويد على امن اوروبا بنفسها لذلك حتى
الان لا يمكن تخمين طبعا الى اي مدى او
الى اين ستذهب موسكو في الرد في حال استمر
حلف الناتو واشنطن بتزويد اوكرانيا بهذه
الاسلحه من الصعب التخمين الى اي مدى سيصل
الرادو ان كان سيكون هناك بالفعل همم حرب
مباشره
بين روسيا وحلف النت وبالاخص ان المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الكريم لان اليوم قال انه حتى
الان لن يتم تغيير وضع العمليه العسكريه
الى حرب روسيا تسميها حتى الان العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيها
وبالتالي روسي حتى الان هي فقط داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه تقوم بالرد وتدمير
جميع الاسلحه التي تصل الى القوات هناك
مراسله العربيه
بمراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
ايه ده مشاهدينا تحدثنا عن امكانيه تقديم
طائرات لكيب من قبل الغرب ايضا هناك
الحديث الذي اصبح معلن الان فيه نوع من
الالتزام من قبل بعض الدول لتقديم
الدبابات هناك تعهد الالماني بتزويد
اوكرانيا باربع 10 دبابه من طراز اليوبارد
اثنين والذي اعتبر ضوء اخضر للحلفاء
لتقديم مثل هذه الدبابات لكيف فما هي
الدول التي تمتلك هذه الدبابات وفقا
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست تمتلك اوروبا الفائده
من طراز اليوبارد اثنين في المجمل 200
منها في بولندا والتي تقول انها مستعده
لتزويد اوكرانيا بخمسه عشره دبابه من
مخزونها وعلى حدود روسيا تقع فنلندا التي
لديها حوالي 200 دبابه من هذا النوع والتي
شدت على انها لا تريد ارسال الدبابات فحس
بل تريد ايضا توفير التدريب وفقا لبلومب
كندا اثنتين وثمانين دبابه من نفس الطراز
ولكن لم يتم ذكر اي اعلان رسمي بشان ما
اذا كانت سترسل دفعه منها الى كياب اما
البلدان الاخرى حيث يمكن العثور على هذه
الدبابات فيها فهي تركيا ب 316 دبابه
واسبانيا التي لديها
108 دبابات اما اليونان فلديها
183 دبابه واخيرا سويسرا والتي تمتلك
1434 دبابه
وعلى الارض رده موسكو على اعلان الغرب
تكثيف امداداتها العسكريه
امطرت روسيا مدن اوكرانيا بوابل من
الصواريخ ما ادى لمقتل شخص على الاقل وقال
مسؤولون في كيف ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاخرانيه اسقطت اكثر من 15 صاروخا روسيا
اطلقت باتجاه العاصمه واعلن في ذلكم وهو
حاكم من تقاطع ميكو لايف رصده صاروخين
روسيين فوق المنطقه وزداد روسيا للبنى
التحتيه المهمه في اوكرانيا بضربات
صاروخيه وطائرات مسيره ما تسبب في انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي على نطاق واسع
وقد اظهرت الصور لجوء الالاف من
الاوكرانيين الى محطات مترو الانفاق في
كيب هربا طبعا من القصف الروسي دعونا
متابع
[موسيقى]
هناك اسرع اخر يدور في اوكرانيا بعيدا عن
العاصمه كيف في شرق البلاد انسحبت القوات
الاوكرانيه من سوليدار فيما لا تزال وحدات
من مجموعه شبه العسكريه الروسيه تتقدم في
باخمود نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني وصفت
المعارك بالشرسه وبالفعل مسؤولون لموسكو
ان القوات الروسيه احكمت سيطرتها على
مواقع في اطراف
هي واقعه على محور جنوب دونتسك على كلن
التفاصيل من دونات اسمع رائد الاخضر
الروسيه التي سيطرت على مدينه
باخم من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه ايضا
كيف من ناحيتها اعلانات الانسحاب بشكل
رسمي من مدينه سوليدار كما ان قوات بانر
تشير الى انها تخوض حرب شوارع في اطراف
المدينه الجنوبيه الشرقيه تشهد مناطق جمال
غرب المدينه ايضا تقدم للقوات الروسيه مثل
مدن افديفكا مارينكا وكذلك برضامايسكا
جنوب المدينه او جنوب المقاطعه يشهد ايضا
سيطره للقوات الروسيه وتقدم نحو مدينه
اوجلادار الحديث عن حرب شوارع ايضا اطراف
المدينه بعد تطويقها والاله العسكريه
الروسيه تقصف القواعد الاوكرانيه المتمرده
داخل المدينه اوغلادور بينما تشهد مقاطعه
زاباروجه ايضا تقدما للقوات الروسيه من
النواحي الجنوبيه الشرقيه وسيطر على بعض
الاراضي وبسط النقود في مدينه
الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
مقتل تسعه فلسطينيين في عمليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في مخيم جنين بالضفه الغربيه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه حذر قاده
الامن السيبراني في المملكه المتحده من ان
روسيا وايران
وبشكل متزايد المسؤولين الحكوميين
والصحفيين
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه بهجمات سبرانيه من
اجل المساومه على الانظمه الحساسه حتى
المركز البريطاني للامن السيبراني الذين
يعملون في هذه الجهات التعرف على التقنيات
والتكتيكات التي يستخدمها المهاجمون مؤكدا
ان هناك مجموعات روسيه وايرانيه استهدفت
مجموعه من المنظمات والافراد في المملكه
المتحده وخارج المملكه طوال عام 20 22
اكد قائد القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم
عبد في مقابله خاصه مع العربي اكد انا قصد
تواصلت مع نظام السوري مشيرا الى ان تركيا
تنويشان عمليه بريه في عين العرب عبدي
توقع ان يعترض الروس والنظام السوري على
شاني عمليه في تل ابيض ومنبج وليس في عين
العرب متابعه
الاطراف
على مناطقنا قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والهجوم الذي سيركزون عليه سيكون في
كوباني
ونتوقع ان تفضي المحادثات الجاريه حاليا
بين الروس والاتراك والنظام السوري الى
مساومه اوصفقه بشان شني عمليه في كوباني
مؤكدا انها ليست جزء منها
سوريون ولدينا واجب نحو سوريا واوضح ذلك
بشكل رسمي على قناه كم بانه لا علاقه
تنظيميه رسميه او صله لنا مع حزب العمال
الكردستاني
كم منظمه سياسيه سوريه ودعيني اضيف شيان
اخر هناك عدد كبير من مقاتل حزب العمال
الكردستاني شاركوا معنا في القتال ضد داعش
ونحو اربعه الاف عنصر منهم قتلوا هنا
وادوا واجبهم القومي الكردي قسم كبير منهم
عاد وقسم اخر بقي عالق هنا
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل تسعه
قتلى وعشرات الجرحى على يد القوات
الاسرائيليه في الاشتباكات العنيفه التي
شهدها مخيم جنين صباح اليوم الوزاره وصفت
الوضع في المخيم بالحرج للغايه وكشفت
مصادر امنيه لوكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه
بان القوات الاسرائيليه اقتحمت المدينه
ومخيم جنين واعلنت اسرائيل حاله التاهب
على الحدود مع الضفه الغربيه
واردنا على المواجهات في مخيم جنين افادت
وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه بنتلاع مواجهات
اخرى بين مواطنين وقوات اسرائيليه في
الخليل وطول كرم بالضفه الغربيه الوكاله
اشارت الى اعلان اضراب شامل في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس حدادا على ارواح قتل
الهجوم الاسرائيلي على مدينه جنين في هذه
الاثناء دعت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الى تحرك
دولي عاجل ردا على الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه
اجل مجلس القضاء الاعلى جلسته للبيت في
قضيه المحقق في قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت
طارق البيطار قالت وسائل الاعلام
اللبنانيه ان التاجيل جاء بعد رفض نصف
اعضاء المجلس عقد الاجتماع بسبب الاجواء
المتوتره شعبيه وقد تصاعدت حده المواجهات
بين البيطار ومدعي عام التمييز غسان
عويدات بعد ان قرر الاخير الاخير عذرا
اخلاء سبيل الموقف فينا في القضيه
في هذه الاثناء نظم اهالي ضحايا انفجار
مرفا بيروت اعتصاما امام وزاره العدل
لمتابعه تطورات التحقيقات في انفجار مرفا
بيروت شهيده محيط قصر العدل في بيروت
مواجهات بين قوات الامن ومحتاجين ماذا فعل
الجيش لارسال تعزيزات الى محيط وزاره
العدل في العاصمه بعد ان حاول المحتجون
اقتحام مقر الوزاره
من بيروت مراسله العربيه ناهد يوسف اهلا
بك ناهد المعلومات لديك تفضلي
امام قصر العدل قبل حوالي ساعتين غادر
الجميع من هنا وذلك بعد ان يعني خلص هذا
التحرك الى عدم انعقاد المجلس مجلس القضاء
الاعلى الذي كانت العين عليه اليوم لمعرفه
ان كان سيبث بقرار تعيين قادم رديف المحقق
اخر عوضا عن المحقق طارق البيطار وهو ما
كان يرفضه الاهالي ولهذا السبب حضروا الى
هنا وخصوصا وان المعلومات كانت تشير الى
تعيين القاضيه همم
مكان القادر وهي همم معروفه بمناسارتها
للتيار الوطني الحر ولذلك كان هذا الرفض
طبعا همم بان يتم تعيينها او تعيين اي
محقق اخر عودا عن القاضي طارق الاعضاء
مجلس القضاء الاعلى رفضوا ان يشارك بس
عندي نقطه همم بحسب بعض التصريحات لبعض
النواب كان هناك حديث انه في طبنانات انه
لن يكون هناك اي تغيير هل في تاكيدات او
لا
هكذا كانت المعلومات التي كنا حصلنا عليها
من عده مصادر قضائيه ان التوجه كان لي
ازاحه او لتعيين قادم بديل ولهذا كان
الحضور اليوم الكفيف من الاهالي ومن
النواب اعضاء مجلس القضاء الاعلى رفضوا ان
يتم انعقاد هذا الاجتماع بحجه ان حضور
النواب هو تدخل سافر في عمل القضاء وانه
لا يمكن انعقاد هكذا اجتماع مع مع تحت ضغط
الشارع ايضا القاضي غسان عويدات الذي عاده
لم يكن يشارك خصوصا انه كان اعلن سابقا
سنحيه عن هذا الملف بسبب صله القرابه بينه
وبين احد المده عليه وهو نائب غزه زعيتر
كان ايضا حضر الى هنا وكان في نيه الحضور
ودخول ونشاركه في هذا الاجتماع بالتصويت
بالاغلبيه يمكن الوصول الى قرار تنحيه
القاضي بيطار وعلي لم يحصل هذا الاجتماع
كان هناك حاله من الهرج والمرج يمكن القول
خارج
اليوم الخارج قصر العدل همم اشتباك او همم
مواجهه بين الاها القوى الامنيه ايضا تعرض
عدد من النواب الى الضرب من قبل مرافقيه
همم وزير العدل وهو الامر المستغرب والذي
يحصل للمره الاولى وكان النائب نائب وضاح
الصادق هو احد النواب الذين تعرضوا للضرب
قال لنا بانه بصدد رفع دعوه على هؤلاء
الذين قاموا بالتعرض له وذلك خلال
اجتماعهم بوزير العدل عندما اجتمع بوزير
العدل ميسون طلب منه التدخل كان يقول بان
هذا الموضوع خارج صلاحياته وانهما طبعا ان
تصل التحقيقات الى خواتيمها ولكنه لن يعلن
ما هي الخطوات التي بصدد اتخاذها ايضا
كانوا اجتمعوا مع رئيس مجلس القضاء الاعلى
سهيل عبود الذي اخبرهم ايضا بانه مع
استمرار التحقيقات ولكنه لم يفضح ان كان
مع بقاء القاضي بيطار ام لا اذن يشير ايضا
ميسون الى انه كانت هناك تصريحات من غسان
عويدات عام التمييز الى عدد من الصحفيين
المعتمدين داخل همم قصر العدل حيث قال
بانه اخلى سبيل انه لو تم اخلاء سبيل همم
الاشخاص الخمسه او الموقوفين الخمسه الذين
كان القاضي بيطار بصدر اقرر اخلاء سبيلهم
فهذا يعني انه اعتراف بقانونيه قرار بقطار
وهو ما لم يحصل وانه ك همم همم كان يعلم
انه ان القاضي بيطار بصدد هكذا قال عويدات
ان اا بثار كان بصدد اخلاء سبيل الجميع
الموقوفين على دفعات ولذلك طلب باخراج همم
بالافراج عنهم دفعه واحده خصوصا وانهم
امضى مده توقفهم الاحتياطي وقال لو انه اي
مرجع قانوني يقول ان هناك ذره قانونيه
بقرار قطار فانه سيعود عن قراره ويعود الى
سجن الموقوفين ولكن هذا الموضوع غير
قانوني هو طبعا يتحدث عن قرار البيطار
وكان طبعا احاله ايضا اليوم الى التفتيش
القضاء وطلبه من الاجهزه الامنيه عدم تسلم
اي مذكره من القاضي
يوسف شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا على كل دعواتنا يا اشير الى
تطورات في الجولان المحتله طبعا المعلومات
وتحديدا من الاعلام السوري تتحدث عن سماع
انفجار عنيف وقع في ريف القنيطره الشمالي
بالقرب من الجولان طبعا ليس لدينا حتى
الان معلومات ولكن لدينا هذه الصور التي
تاتينا الان لهذا الانفجار العنيف الذي
وقع كما ذكرنا في ريف القنيطره همم
الشمالي طبعا بالقرب من الجولان
اطلقت الولايات المتحده واسرائيل اكبر
منوره عسكريه مشتركه لهما والتي شملت
اسلحه استراتيجيه مثل مقاتلات جويه من
طراز اف 35 وانظمه اطلاق الصواريخ همرس
التي استعان بها الجيش الاوكراني ضد
القوات الروسيه المتابعه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
شركه متى تعلن عوده حسابات ترامب المعلقه
في فيسبوك وانستغرام
اهلا بيكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلن رئيس
مجلس السياده الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح
البرهان بعد لقائه برئيس وزراء اثيوبيا
ابي احمد ان البلدين متفقان على كافه
القضايا المتعلقه بسد النهضه مؤكدا على ان
الوثائق والاليات الفنيه تمثل المرجعيه
الاساسيه لقضيه الحدود البرهان اضاف ان
تجربه السلامه في تجرايد تعتبر مشرفه
وتدعم الاستقرار في اثيوبيا من جانبه اكد
ابي احمد للبرهان ان الغرض من الزياره هو
اظهار التضامن مع السودان والوقوف معهم
مشددا على ان سد النهضه لا يسبب ضررا
للسودان بل سيعود عليه بالنفع واضاف انه
لا يقدم مقترحات جديده ويثق في قدره
السودانيين على تجاوز قضاياهم
في تركيا يعقد قاده ما تعرف بالطاوله
المستديره السداسيه والتي تتكون طبعا من
رؤساء سته احزاب تركيه معارضه يعقدون
اجتماعا للاتفاق على تسميه مرشح للمعارضه
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله امام
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ويجمع اللقاء الذي
يعقد في مقر حزب الخير بالعاصمه التركيه
انقره يجمع مجموعه من الاسماء المعارضه
ومن ابرزهم رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
بلو رئيس اكبر احزاب المعارضه التركيه
والذي عبر مرارا عن رغبته بالترشح للرئاسه
ويعاد من ابرز الاسماء المطروحه لمنافسه
اردوغان
معنى من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان
زنجلو اهلا بك زيدان خبرنا اكثر عن هذا
الاجتماع والتفاصيل والتوقعات
الحادي عشر للطاوله السداسيه او زعماء
الطاوله السداسيه بدا قبل حوالي خمس ساعات
من الان في العاصمه التركيه انقره طبعا لا
شك ان القضيه الرئيسيه التي تشغل جمهور
المعارضه هي موضوع المرشح المشترك
للمعارضه في وجه الرئيس او ضد الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان هذا الموضوع كان
يشغل الاوساط المعارضه هنا في تركيا
الاسيما ان خلافات نشبت بين اطراف من
الطاوله السداسيه بعد صدور قرار المحكمه
التركيه بحبس همم منتصف ديسمبر الماضي
بحبس اكرم امام اوغلو رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
وحرمان من العمل السياسي هناك كان جدل همم
حول ترشيح كليدار وكانه لا يحظى بذات
الشعبيه في الشارع همم كشخصيات مثل الاكرم
امام اوبر رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ومن سوريا
واش رئيس بلديه انقره لكن على ما يبدو
اليوم ان الامور تغيرت ولاسيه مع ان وفد
رؤساء بلديات المعارضه زاره يوم امس كمال
كلشدار اوغلو في مقر حزبه في العاصمه
انقره وكان من ضمن ضمن الوفد طبعا من
سوريا واش رئيس بلديه انقره واكرم ممامه
للرئيس بلديه اسطنبول وابدا هذا الوفد
دعمه لترشيح اكرم عفوا كماك الجدار
الاردني يبدو ان قضيه المرشح المشترك تسير
نحو التوافق على كماك الجدار اوغلو زعيم
المعارضه التركيه هذه نقطه نقطه اخرى لكن
حتى اليوم طبعا في هذا الاجتماع لن يتم
الاعلان عن شخصيه المرشح من المتوقع ان
يتم الاعلان في منتصف فبراير القادم
زيدان ذكرت انه شعبيته ليست بنفس المستوى
همم لشعبيات همم اخرين منع ربما من
المشاركه ولكن النقطه الرئيسيه اذا ما كان
هناك توافق من قبل الاحزاب فان الولاءات
في الشارع ستميل الى ما تريد الاحزاب او
لا
[موسيقى]
يسعى اليه كمان
زعيم المعارضه يريد ويعتقد انه في حال تم
التوافق عليه كمرشح مشترك من قبل جميع
اطراف المعاد او نتحدث فقط عن احزاب
الطاوله السداسيه ربما هذا سيعزز موقفه او
موقف زعيم المعارضه في الشارع همم بغض
النظر عن استطلاعات الراي التي كانت تضعه
في المرتبه الثالثه خرف خلف منصور واكرم
امام اوغلو في حال دخل هؤلاء الانتخابات
همم هذه نقطه يعول عليها شيء همم
ويريد كسب الطبقه المحافظه تحديدا من خلال
دعم حزبي المستقبل
وحزب همم
وايضا زعيم همم
ذهب عن بالي الاسم حزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم علي بابا جان زعيم هذا الحزب
الذين الذين كانوا في حزب العداله
والتنميه وانشق عن هذا الحدب هذا الحزب
يريد كل الجدار اوغلو دعم هؤلاء
وتحديدا الطبقه المحافظه التي تؤيدها هذه
الحزبين لمحاوله على يعتقد الموازنه في
اصوات الشارع
رجب طيب اردوغان حظوظه وشعبيته الان ولا
اي حد الغزل مع سوريا يمكن له ان يعطيه
دفعه جديده او لا
لا شك في استطلاعات الراي التي كانت تضع
اردوغان في مقابل الجدار اوغلو كانت الكفه
تميل لصالح الرئيس التركي هذا هذه كل
استطلاعات راي كانت اقرتها حتى
استطلاعات الراي من مراكز ابحاث مقربه من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعرض لكن هذا
الموضوع ربما او يعني لا يمكن التكهن به
الان قبل اشهر من الانتخابات المتوقع ان
تكون في الخامس عشر من مايو لا شك ان
خطوات اردوغان اا ولاسيهما في صعيد على
صعيد السياسه الخارجيه تحديدا في الملف
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وايضا اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب ومؤخرا همم الحديث عن تطبيع
العلاقات مع النظام واعاده اللاجئين همم
فيما يسميها اردوغان العوده الطوعيه الى
سوريا لا شك ان هذا الموضوع ربما يعطي
اردوغان حضوضا في هذه الملفات لكن هناك
عوامل اخرى لا يجب ان نهملها في هذه
الانتخابات وهو العامل الداخلي والتحدث
تحديدا عن العامل الاقتصادي تركيا لا شك
ان عانت العام الماضي من اسوا الظروف
الاقتصاديه وكان هناك اعلى معدل للتضخم
منذ 20 عاما لكن خلال الايام والاسابيع
الاخيره بدات تحدث التضخم وارقام تضخم
بالانخفاض تدريجيا لكن حتى الان ازمه
التضخم ما زالت تؤثر في الشارع رغم كل
الاجراءات التي يحاول اردوغان انجازها قبل
وصول موعد الانتخابات
نبقى في تركيا حيث قال وزير خارجيه تركيا
مولود تشاوش اوغلو قال ان عقد اجتماع مع
فنلندا والسويد في هذه المرحله امر عبسي
كما اشار الوزير لانه لا يوجد عرض رسمي
لفصل ملف انضمام فنلندا للنت عن السويد
وقد تزايد التوتر بين السويد وتركيا على
خلفيه حرق المصحف الشريف امام السفاره
التركيه في السوق هون وسماح السلطات
السويديه لمظاهرات لانه شطاء اكراد وهو ما
اثار حفيظه انقره في المقابل
في تطورات الاوضاع في افغانستان طالبات
الامارات واليابان وفرنسا مجلس الامن
الدولي بعقد مشاورات مغلقه حول اوضاع
النساء في كابول من المقرر ان تقدم امينه
محمد وهي نائبه الامين العام للامم
المتحده ملخصه زيارتها الاخيره الى
افغانستان بما في ذلك مشاركتها والرسائل
التي وجهتها وتقييمها حول الاوضاع هناك من
جهتها حذرت امين محمد الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي من قطع المساعدات
الانسانيه عن افغانستان على الرغم من
تضييق حركه طالبان الحاكمه على حقوق
المراه
[موسيقى]
طبعا تمريرات المسؤوله الاماميه جاءت في
وقت تفاقم في الازمه الانسانيه في
افغانستان وتتاكل فيه ايضا حقوق المراه
طبعا هو وضع يتطلب تدخلا امنيا عاجلا بحسب
مراقبين في الايام القليله الماضيه عمل
اعضاء الامم المتحده على مدار الساعه من
اجل الضغط على طالبان لتقديم بعض
الاستثناءات من الحظر المطبق على النساء
الافغانيات خلال زياره استمرت اربعه ايام
الى كابول ركز مارتن كرفس وهو منسق
مساعدات الامم المتحده في كابول كتفه
جهوده على الغاء الحظر المفروض على عمل
النساء الافغانيات في المنظمات الانسانيه
غير الحكوميه جدير بالذكر ان افغانستان
تواجهه اسماء الازمات الانسانيه في العالم
حيث يهدد الجوع اكثر من نصف سكانها من
بينهم اربعه ملايين طفل كانت النساء
والافغانيات يقومن بدور حاسم في تقديم
المساعدات لكن مع الحضر المفروض عليهن فقد
يزداد الوضع سوء وسط مخ من ان تشمل القيود
العاملات الاجنبيات في المساعدات الدوليه
بالنسبه للامم المتحده فهناك امل ضعيف في
ان تخفف طالبان من قائمه الحظر ما يشجع
هذا الامل حتى الان على الاقل هو منح حركه
طالبان بعض الاستثناءات في قطاع الصحه
في الفتره التي مازال فيها الحظر ساري
المفعول انا ود رؤيه توسيع بعض
الاستثناءات في قطاعات معينه من العمليات
الانسانيه نريد ان نرى هذا النهضه يتوسع
ليشمل جميع قطاعات العمليات الانسانيه حتى
نتمكن من العوده الى العمل الانساني
الكامل اخبرني عدد من قاده طالبان ان
الحركه كاداره تعمل على مبادئ توجيهيه
وستوفر مزيده من الوضوح حول دور وحريه
المراه في العمل الانساني
انني احب افغانستان والمجتمع الدولي على
الاهتمام الجاد بنا لان الشتاء شديد
البروده هذا العام والناس يموتون
ولا منقد واطفالنا ليس لديهم ملابس دافئه
يرتدونها
خلال الصباح الباكر والليل يصبح الطقس
شديد البروده معظم طلابنا لا يستطيعون
النوم ياتي بعد الطلاب الاكبر سنا ولكن
الصغار لا يستطيع ذلك
التحديات
في كابول
ان تفتح مركزا للخياطه بمساعدته ثلاثه من
زميلاتها ويوفرنا فرص عمل لعشرات النساء
دعنا
ابواب الجامعات امامها وامام زميلاتها
تفتتح حسناء مركزا للخياطه والتطريز
لتتعلم فيه هي وزميلاتها تقول حسنا انها
طالبه في جامعه كابول في السنه الرابعه
والاخيره وكانت ستتخرج هذا العام
التي تعيشها السيدات الافغانيات فقط فتحت
هذا المركز لتشييع السيدات على العمل من
جهه والايجاد فرصه للعمل لهن من جهه اخرى
في الدراسه وفي العمل تقول لقد تم حرمانها
وزميلاتها من مواصله الدراسه في الجامعه
ولكي تقدم خدمات ولو بسيطه للشريحه
المظلومه من النساء بدات العمل في هذا
المركز
استقبلته رسائل مشجعه من زميلاتي في
الدراسه على بدء مشروع فخططت انا مع السيد
حسناء الافتتاحي هذا المركز لتقديم فرصه
تعليم الخياطه لفتياتي وسيدات البلده حتى
يستطيعن التغلب على هذه الظروف الصعبه
التي يعشناها عدد السيدات يصل في هذا
المركز حاليا الى 25 بين معلمه ومتعلمه
يتناوبنا على ثلاث ماكينات قديمه للخياطه
والتي تكلف كل واحده منها 20 دولارا وتشغل
يدويا بطريقه تقليديه صعبه
تقول سيدات في هذا المركز انهن يواجهن
تحديات اقتصاديه يصعب التغلب عليها في هذه
الظروف الصعبه ساعيات الى توسيعه انشطتهن
وذلك على الرغم من عدم تقديم دعم لهن حتى
الان عبد الله نادر العربيه
قالت المفاوضات الاوروبيه للشؤون الداخليه
الفا جوهانسن ان الاتحاد الاوروبي تلقى ما
يزيد من مليون طلب في العام الماضي مؤكده
على انه سيتم تحقيق تقدم كبير لزياده عوده
الطالب اللجوء بشكل اسرع واكثر فعاليه
من المهاجرين وعلى الرغم من ان لدينا
حوالي 300,000 عام الماضي الا اننا تلقينا
ما يقرب من مليون طلب في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا يعني ان لدينا طلبات اللجوء اكثر
بثلاث مرات من الوافدين غير النظاميين
والعديد منهم لا يحتاجون الى الحمايه
الدوليه كما ان لدينا معدله عائد منخفض
للغايه ويمكنني ان ارى اننا نستطيع تحقيق
تقدم كبير لزياده عدد العائدات وجعلها
اكثر فعاليه واسرع
بعد عامين من التعليق قررت شركه ميتر رفع
الحظر عن حسابات الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب على فيسبوك وانستغرام
فاكيف كيف علقت ترامب على هذا القرار دعم
المتابعه
من جديد بعد عامين اعلنت متى رفع الحظر عن
حساباته ليعود الى واجهه الاحداث فيسبوك
علق حساب ترامب عام 2021 عقب اعمال الشغب
التي شهدها مبنى الهاتف
لم يغفر لها ترامب هيثود لا يزال ويفضل
منصفته سوشي
مره اخرى لا ينبغي حظر حساب اي رئيس
فيسبوك خسر مليارات الدولارات بعد حضره
ترامب والاخير قد يستفيد من المنصه مستبقا
لانتخابات 2424
حركه السيارات وايضا تجول السكان في سيول
بسبب عاصفه الجيش
[موسيقى]
الخميس انتهت شكرا متابعه مشاهدينا